Hey everybody.
Thanks for sticking around. I think
I might be one of the last few
sessions that are
happening. So thank you for uh
for stopping by.
So today I'm gonna talk a little
bit about how Grepper's real-time machine
learning can actually help you get 100%
of the observability that you're seeing today
at 10% of the cost.
I'll start with a little bit of talking
about the AI for telemetry problem because that's
something that people always face,
and I'll talk about extracting
signal from that data so you can
actually feed it into AI
and I'll talk a bit about how Grupper works to get there.
So if you think about how people have been
working with observability for the past,
I don't know, 1520 years,
it all started with full stack observability
where you would collect the data from
the agents,
send it into an application,
um, and that application, that aggregator
is a full stack aggregator, kind
of a walled garden that defines
what you can actually do with that application,
not more with that data.
And then over time we started seeing
more openness in these observability platforms,
more modularization,
where Otel came in as a protocol
to separate the data collection
from the
data aggregators, and then we started
seeing telemetry pipelines as well.
And so what happens after that is
we want to enable AI powered ops
and workflows, and this is what everybody's talking
about today.
We want to empower SREs and
DevOps to be able to handle enormously
more complex
operations and systems.
But the biggest problem with AI systems
today is that the data
is just enormous and it's mostly
noise,
so everything that you're collecting is maybe you'll
ever need maybe 1% of it.
And if you were to feed all that data
into an AI model and tell it, hey,
figure out what's actually in there, it's really
garbage in and garbage out.
And so the biggest problem with
using AI
for observability is the ability
to de-noise the data and figure out how to
concentrate it, so you can actually have
clean data for these systems.
And really that's what Grapper does.
So the way Greppers works is you
start, let's say, with your existing deployments,
you're collecting data, logs, traces,
metrics.
That data is going into your observability
vendor, you know, maybe Splunk,
Data Dog, Grafana, whatever it is.
And Grepper sits in the middle.
We automatically figure out
what is noisy, what's not noisy, what
are all the patterns that are in your
data,
and we use that to figure out how
much volume is actually passing
through each of those patterns.
And we can, we can use that pattern to
understand, OK, what, how do we give you full
coverage of your application.
By passing through data for all of those
patterns and making sure that we don't miss
anything that might be useful.
And so this is all automatic.
It works out of the box.
We automatically look at the data, we automatically
figure out what are the patterns.
We can operate on millions of patterns
in the data.
Today we're doing this for logs and traces,
and we're building metrics next year.
So the way that Grepper
works for logs is as the data's passing
through in real time, we're figuring
out what are the patterns in those logs.
And so here in this example, we're
seeing that hey, there's two patterns in the
data. There's these gets and then there's
these posts.
And what we do is we pass through those
initial few samples for each
of those patterns,
and once we have enough samples, then we say, hey,
we've seen enough of those log messages,
let's actually start
reducing them.
And then at the end of a 2 minute window, we'll
send you a summary saying, hey, we've seen this much
of this pattern, we've seen that much of this pattern,
and we can also aggregate data inside
of those patterns so that we can say things
like we've seen
an average latency of this much or
this many bytes actually passed through.
So this allows you to get
exactly the data that you need,
high signal data
passed through downstream, whether to AI
models or down to your observability
vendor. And all of
this is super configurable, so you can make it
be 1 minute instead of 2 minutes.
You can change and decide, hey, I don't want
to aggregate this pattern. I want to pass it through.
We do things like automatically figure out
what are the logs that are powering your dashboards
and alerts, and we can
automatically add them into Grepper so that we
don't modify or we don't
change your workflows and impact
them if you roll it out.
For traces, we do something similar.
So if you're familiar with tail sampling,
the way that it works is you
look at the endpoints of
the traces, like where they're hitting, where they're getting
started, and then you start
looking at the performance of each of those endpoints.
But there's a problem here.
What if that endpoint is sometimes cached
and sometimes not cached?
So that means that your data
or your traces actually have different paths
depending on whether the data is cached or not.
So in this example, we're seeing all of the traces
actually starting at a circle,
and we have two red ones. One
actually has only 2 hops,
and the other one has
4 hops, 3 hops,
something like that.
And so.
You want to actually look at the performance
of these two paths differently, even though
they start at the same endpoint.
And so what we do is we actually look at the full
structure of every trace
to map out your entire application
and be able to understand, OK, here are all
the things that we need to
pass through and make sure that the end user
is aware of.
No Then
we keep track of the performance
of each of those different signatures of
these full structures,
which allows us to understand when is this
particular path slow and when is that particular
path fast.
And then we can drop the noisy
data, the stuff that's actually unnecessary,
and give you full
sampling across your entire
application so we can cover everything.
But ultimately no data is ever lost.
So what we do is we put all the
raw data into an observability data
lake,
which allows us to keep that data
in at low cost
for a very long time.
You can keep it as long as you wanted it to.
And it can always be queried.
You can, if you ever wanted to go find a log
message from
6 months ago, you can go and look
at it. You don't have to do a hydration,
but if you wanted to, you could go and backfill that
data back into your observability vendor,
or you could
have it
be triggered to be manually
backfilled or automatically backfilled.
So you can hook up this backfill,
let's say, to a ticketing system.
If a customer
opens a particular ticket, maybe you want to go
and load all the logs that
are relevant for that customer
or all the traces that are relevant for that
customer,
or maybe you have some anomaly or
fraud detection system that you want
to hook up so that when an analyst
finds that there's an anomaly, they're
already all the logs are already there in your end
system for them to go and troubleshoot.
And what we've seen as results are
very encouraging from our customers. We
see over 90%
reduction in many cases with very
minimal impact
to developer workflows.
Grepper usually takes about 30 minutes to
get started with. You just set it
up. You get,
you point your existing agents into
Grepper, and Grepper automatically
starts working to figure out what are all the patterns,
do the compression,
and send the data through.
So this changes that
conversation with your developers or your
SREs who are trying to figure out, OK, well
how do I,
how do I even get started? I've got 100
teams, they're all using logs or
traces,
and I need to really cut down this spend,
but I'm not really sure where to start.
Do I start looking at patterns one by
one and adding drop filters and sampling
rates for these patterns?
What we do is we just set it up automatically
for you. And that changes the
conversation from being, hey, here's a blank slate, do
something, learn this
thing, get certified in it,
to a place where it's actually more
about tuning.
So you set that, set it up, it starts
working.
You look at the data that's passing through.
You can make decisions. Is this good? Is this
enough? Do I need more?
And you can do that as time moves on because
ultimately there's no risk.
The data's all in the data lake. So if you ever needed
something that isn't actually forwarded,
you can always go back into the data lake to fetch
it. You'll always find everything there,
but this makes it really easy to roll out
Grepper
with the assurance that.
Your data is going to be there
without impacting workflows and actually increasing
MTTR.
Thank you.
This is a very quick talk because Grepper
is actually very fast and easy to
describe, but I'm happy to
take any questions since we've got
about 10 minutes left.